Bonjour!
Si je vous dis Mozart, je pense que c'est un nom
qui vous parle. En tout cas il me parle, bien sûr,
c'était quand même le nom de mon chat.
Mais outre un célèbre compositeur et
un chat exceptionnel, le nom de
Mozart désigne aussi Nannerl, sœur
méconnue de Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart qui aurait
tellement mérité de rester dans les mémoires.
Maria Anna Mozart, surnommée Nannerl,
est née le 30 juillet 1751 à Salzbourg,
cinq ans avant son petit-frère Wolfgang. Leur
père, Léopold Mozart, est un concertiste,
joueur de clavecin et de violon, au service
du prince-archevêque de Salzbourg. Le couple
Mozart a cinq autres enfants, mais
seuls Nannerl et Wolfgang survivent.
Durant leur enfance les deux enfants sont
très proches, allant jusqu'à s'inventer
leur propre langage secret et leur univers
imaginaire. Lorsque papa Mozart commence à
enseigner le piano à Nannerl, qui a alors
sept ans, Wolfgang se trouve à ses côtés.
Wolfgang et Nannerl révèlent vite un potentiel
impressionnant, elle et son frère sont capables
de transposer en notes n'importe quel air,
de jouer les pièces les plus difficiles,
d'improviser... Leur père les emmène à travers
les villes d'Europe pour qu'ils se produisent.
"Dieu [leur] a donné de tels talents que je serais
contraint, même si ce n'était mon devoir paternel,
de tout sacrifier à leur bonne éducation.
Chaque instant perdu l'est à jamais", écrit-il.
Lors de leur première tournée, Nannerl a onze
ans et Wolfgang six. Les deux enfants enchantent
tous les publics qu'ils rencontrent, de cours
princières en concerts privés tout le monde
s'extasie quand Mozart est làOn raconte d'eux
qu'ils sont capables de jouer du clavecin les yeux
fermés, le clavier recouvert d'un drap ou avec un
seul doigt... Wolfgang est plus en vue, étant plus
jeune, mais Nannerl partage toujours l'estrade
avec lui, jouant ou chantant. Leur père écrit
aussi à son propos: «Ma petite fille joue les
pièces les plus difficiles que nous avons... avec
une incroyable précision et tant d'excellence.
Ce que je veux dire est que ma petite fille,
bien qu'elle n'ait que douze ans, est l'un
des musiciens les plus talentueux d'Europe».
Son talent est aussi vanté par le comte
Karl von Zinzendorf qui assiste à l'une
de leurs représentations: «Le petit garçon de
Salzbourg et sa sœur jouent du clavecin. Le pauvre
petit garçon joue merveilleusement,
c'est un enfant spirituel, vivant,
charmant. Le jeu de sa sœur est magistral, et
il l'applaudissait». Wolfgang dit plus tard,
dans une lettre, que personne ne joue
aussi bien ses compositions que sa sœur.
Nannerl est non seulement une excellente
interprète, mais elle compose des pièces.
Son frère l'encourage beaucoup et joue notamment
une de ses œuvres lors de l'un de ses concerts,
révélant seulement à la fin du morceau
qu'elle a été écrite par sa sœur. Cela
provoque la colère de leur père, qui
interdit dès lors à Nannerl d'écrire
de la musique car une fille ne peut pas
devenir compositrice, c'est comme ça.
Car oui, vous l'aurez deviné, la grande
malédiction de Nannerl est sa famille et
surtout son père qui bride son talent.
À 18 ans, elle est en âge de se marier,
et s'il était mignon qu'une petite fille
se produise en concert, c'est un peu moins
accepté de la part d'une jeune femme...
Son père se concentre dès lors uniquement
sur la carrière de Wolfgang. Il refuse
que Nannerl apprenne le violon, cesse
de l'emmener en tournée... Nannerl doit rester
à la maison et donner des leçons de piano pour
financer les tournées de son frère. Ses rêves
sont brisés, elle commence une dépression.
Cette situation éloigne le frère, dont la
carrière décolle et qui part souvent en tournée,
et la sœur restée à Salzbourg. Surtout après
le mariage de Wolfgang car Nannerl déteste sa
femme. Nannerl désire elle-même se marier,
avec le capitaine Franz d'Ippold dont elle
est très amoureuse, mais son père refuse
cette union. Wolfgang propose alors à sa
sœur de venir le rejoindre à Vienne avec son
capitaine pour vivre leur amour hors mariage,
mais elle se résigne. Son père lui fait
épouser en 1784 le magistrat Johann Baptist
Franz von Berchtond Zu Sonnenburg,
un veuf déjà père de cinq enfants.
De cette union, Nannerl a trois enfants
dont un meurt en bas âge. Elle reste à la
maison et s'occupe de Leopold, Jeannette
et des enfants de son mari, leur apprend
la musique, mais aucun n'a son talent.
Même si elle n'avait plus que des contacts
brefs avec son frère, ses lettres restent pleines
d'affection. La dernière lettre de Wolfgang montre
même qu'il tente un rapprochement avec elle, même
s'il avait aussi un service à lui demander...
"Soeur chérie !
"Tu aurais raison
d'être fâché contre moi ! - Mais le seras-tu
encore lorsque la diligence t'aura apporté mes
dernières compositions pour piano ? - Oh non !
- Cela remettra, j'espère, les choses en place.
"Comme tu seras convaincue que je souhaite
vraiment chaque jour toutes sortes de choses
agréables pour toi, tu me pardonneras d'arriver
un peu en retard avec mes vœux de bonne fête.
[...] Ma chère sœur ! Tu ne peux pas douter
que j'aie fort à faire - et tu sais fort bien
que je suis quelque peu paresseux pour
écrire des lettres - tu ne m'en voudras
donc pas si je t'écris rarement. [...]
"Je dois maintenant te demander quelque
chose : j'aimerais que Haydn (1) me prête
pour quelque temps les partitions de ses
deux messes en tutti et les graduels qu'il a
composés [...]. Invite-le à venir te voir et
joue- lui mes nouvelles compositions - le trio
et le quatuor ne lui déplairont pas. Adieu,
sœur chérie ! - dès que j'aurai
rassemblé de nouvelles musiques,
je te les enverrai - je suis à jamais
ton frère sincère, W. A. Mozart"
La mort de Wolfgang en 1791 est l'occasion
pour Nannerl de trouver un nouveau but:
elle honore la mémoire de son frère en rassemblant
ses compositions et les lettres qu'ils se sont
échangés durant toutes ces années. Lorsqu'un
biographe la contacte en 1792 pour qu'elle
réponde à quelques questions, elle ne parle
que de leur enfance et de leurs tournées,
et ne dit rien de la carrière de Wolfgang à
partir du moment où leurs chemins se séparent.
La parution d'une autre biographie en 1800 lui
fait toutefois prendre conscience de la fin de
vie difficile de son frère: «La biographie
de Mr. Prof. Niemetschek a complètement ravivé
mes sentiments fraternels envers mon frère,
si ardemment aimé que souvent je sanglotais,
ne m’étant aperçu qu’il y a peu de la triste
condition dans laquelle il se trouvait.»
À la mort de son mari, elle
recommence à donner des cours
de piano pour subvenir à ses besoins.
Elle devient aveugle en 1825, et meurt le
29 octobre 1829 à 78 ans. Aucune œuvre signée
d'elle ne nous est parvenue. Dans une lettre
de son frère, qui répondait à une composition
qu'elle lui avait envoyé, il s'exclame: «Ma
chère sœur! Je suis admiratif que vous composiez
si bien, en un mot, le morceau que vous avez écrit
est beau». On sait aussi qu'elle a orchestré la
première symphonie de son frère. Puisque Nannerl
écrivait les compositions de Wolfgang à sa place,
lorsqu'il était trop jeune pour les mettre par
écrit, il est possible que certains des morceaux
attribués à Wolfgang soient en réalité d'elle.
Sa vie a été racontée dans un film, «Nannerl, la
sœur de Mozart», et dans une pièce de théâtre,
«The Other Mozart». Dans son roman «Une
Chambre à Soi», Virginia Woolf imaginait un
instant une sœur aussi douée que son frère à
Shakespeare et les difficultés qu'elle aurait
rencontrées pour faire connaître son talent. Si
elle avait connu l'existence de Nannerl Mozart,
elle n'aurait pas eu besoin de fiction pour étayer
son propos; mais à l'époque où Virginia écrivait,
Nannerl avait déjà depuis longtemps sombré dans
l'oubli. Si ses travaux sont probablement perdus
pour toujours, on peut au moins faire
ressurgir son existence, et s'imaginer
en écoutant quelques pièces de Wolfgang que
sa sœur se trouve derrière certaines idées.